je suis quand même le premier joueur
avoir fait ma formation complète à Orlan
et avoir signé pro directement après
donc ça me tient à cœur de commencer ma
carrière
ici c'est l'histoire d'un homme patient
d'une ascension régulière l'histoire
d'un ado déterminé Noah bolonga débarque
à 15 ans à Orléan avec des rêves plein
la tête l'ancien capitaine de l'équipe
Espoir grime dans
grill les étapes c'est une continuité du
travail j'ai commenc à travailler avec
avec Pierre qui assistant avec l'équipe
pro cétait mon premier coach arriv
ici est dans la raqu
avch un entraîneur exigeant
rigoureux tu veux le dire trich et aussi
un
pe préhension d'aller complètement dans
le monde pro et làdessus là-dessus il en
est conscient et donc il met les choses
en place pour travailler quotidiennement
pour réussir son objectif derrière la
ligne à TR points c'est quelqu'un qui a
une forte réussite une vitesse de tir
importante et puis qui a une fraîcheur
voilà il aime le basket quand il sourit
à l'entraînement c'est parce que lui il
prend du plaisir à jouer au basket c'est
pas un travail pour lui dans sa tête
aujourd'hui Noah a 20 ans et ça y est le
voilà dans le
[Applaudissements]
grand
regardez-moi ce pétard là de dynamite le
petitjeune répond aux attentes il
devient un des artificiers en chef de
l'attaque de
l'OLB pourtant sa confiance est toujours
en construction je cherche encore un peu
ma place c'est le début de saison donc
voilà on prend notre temps mais je me
vois comme le jeune un peu qui doit
appter sa fraîcheur son
énergie plein de promesses et déjà un
joli palmarès cet été Noah devient
champion d'Europe avec avec l'équipe de
France des moins de 20 ans même les
générations les plus prometteuses du
basket français n'avaient pas remporté
ce titre parkerur bathou Fournier Gobert
aucun de ces immenses joueurs n'a tenu
cette médaille là entre ses mains
c'était vraiment une aventure j'ai passé
un mois et demi avec avec des joueurs
sans voir ma famille donc voilà on on
est vraiment devenu très proche ce petit
bout de tissu c'est un morceau du filet
du terrain d'raaclyon c'est assez
symbolique et ça se fait régulièrement
dans les compétitions internationales
donc donc voilà c'était le petit plus
qui allait avec la médaille
c'est vrai que ça me prend pas mal de
temps le sport et j'essaie quand même de
garder un moment pour les choses à côté
et pouvoir pouvoir penser autre que
basket basket basket et casser cette
caricature évidemment de le sportif ne
pense qu'à son sport et voilà j'aime
l'art mais j'aime aussi la Mode j'aime
le design avant le basket j'avais pensé
à faire des études de
graphisme cette petite fleur c'est en
rapport avec ma mère voilà ma mère aime
beaucoup les fleurs aime beaucoup
symbolise un peu la Renaissance parce
qu'une fleur c'est c'est un cycle donc
c'est une graine qui pousse qui fleurit
qui fanne et qui repousse c'est c'est
assez représentatif de de la vie il y a
des moments durs il y a des moments un
peu plus faciles et le plus important
c'est c'est de se
relever en direct ce matin en studio à
nos côté sur France Bleu Orléan c'est
Germain castanau l'entraîneur de
l'orléan Loiré
basket l'objectif du club il est il est
très clair c'est de pas y rester dans
cette Dee division est-ce que vous vous
mettez un peu plus de pression je peux
pas dire le contraire voilà même quand
je vais acheter mon mon pain le matin le
boulanger me rappelle qu'il faut monter
cette année donc voilà tout le monde me
le répète tous les jours en même temps
c'est le défi il a toujours une tournure
une petite phrase qu'on reprend dans la
matinale le lendemain et c'est toujours
un plaisir de le passer qu'il est gagné
ou pas d'ailleurs avec son équipe on
aime parce que même quand un match est
mauvais il l'assume et il tape quand
même souvent du du point sur la table
puis il a un vrai Fran parl qui qui
devient culte un peu maintenant dans le
milieu du sport
bon client grande gueule Germain Castano
incarne l'OLB exaspérant pour certains
attachant pour beaucoup ma vie c'est
l'OLB aujourd'hui et j'ai qu'une chose
qui m'intéresse c'est l'institution qui
s'appelle l'OLB chacune de ces
conférences de presse est un événement
vous avez vu des mecs qui se faisaient
plaisir un peu sur le terrain j'ai
l'impression que les mecs son' ennuy sur
le terrain on est dans le rouge
physiquement il y a des mecs qui
avancent plus mais au moins montrer un
petit peu d'émotion amusez-vous quoi et
si on craque sur la parce qu'on a plus
d'essens on a plus d'essens j'aime pas
prendre les journalistes pour les cons
j'aime pas j'aime bien voilà je dis les
choses que j'ai à dire par contre j'aime
bien protéger mes joueurs ça c'est sûr
mais quand j'ai une phrase qui sort un
peu du contexte je la sors comme je la
sens quoi je je mets pas trop de forme
parfois dans les années 90- 2000 Germain
Castano joue comme meneur à Chalon surs
à besonçon ou encore à mulouse mais
après sa carrière il se révèle surtout
comme entraîneur au Palais des Sports
d'Orléan il vit l'adrénaline des
play-offs comme la des illusion d'une
relégation moi j'ai vu des gens ici
pleurer de joie et pleurer de de peine
mais c'est le sport après ça ça partira
plus jamais c'est ici puis il ressent la
ferveur des 10000 spectateurs de l'Arena
comète écoutez ça écoutez
ça c'est
l'émotion attaque
attaque pass
pour pour moi c'est même pas un métier
c'est une passion j'ai la chance de
venir tous les jours au travail j'ai
j'ai jamais eu ça fait 20 ans que je
suis entraîneur j'ai jamais eu
l'impression de travailler un seul jour
donc ça c'est un vrai luxe on enchaîne
hein là là-bas on enchaîne allez go
c'est parti aujourd'hui il est à la tête
d'une équipe renouvelée mais ambitieuse
et parfois ces joueurs ont besoin d'être
stimulé réveillé on joue à domicile il
faut qu'on le rentre dedans on joue à
marchant c'est la branlette là il y en a
un qui sort là on dirait un grand-père
vous êtes
sérieux c'est du basket
ça il faut le scouer moi j'aime bien êre
dur mais juste voilà aujourd'hui j'ai
pas eu l'impression qu'on prépara un
match important dans 48 he donc il
fallait les scouer un petit peu
et faut répéter les choses vous savez
c'est une jeune équipe en plus un
entraînement du matin il y en a sont pas
du tout du matin et ça ça peut agacer
les entraîneurs parfois mais
l'entraîneur agace rarement ces joueurs
c'est un
coach en fait il te laisse beaucoup de
liberté et même au
quotidien agréable tu peux parler avec
lui il est naturel et franchement il m'a
il m'a apporté une vraie fraîcheur moi
c'est ce que j'avais besoin
reconnaissant ver Germain c'est le
premier coach à m'avoir donné la chance
de pouvoir mettre un pied sur un terrain
professionnel donc ce sera toujours une
personne spéciale qui est très porté sur
les valeurs humaines donc voilà c'est
assz facile de discuter avec lui il est
capable d'entendre d'entendre ce qu'on
lui propose d'entendre voilà quand on
n'est pas d'accord avec
[Musique]
lui
je pense que le pion me représente bien
quand il traverse les Chiers il peut
devenir n'importe quelle autre pièce une
reine un cavalier ou un fou par
exemple vu d'où je viens vu comment j'ai
grandi en tant que personne et aussi en
tant que basketteur forcément ça
raisonne en
moi c'est un stratège un chef
d'orchestre un meneur d',6 loin d'être
une tour mais sa vitesse et son coup
d'œil ont de quoi rendre fou Stéphan
Smith futur roi
d'Orléan on veut attaquer à droite donc
on fait semblant d'attaquer à gauche le
basket sur les systèmes de jeu c'est un
peu pareil donc il est loin d'être c'est
un jeune joueur mais c'est pas il est
pas immature du tout dans son jeu c'est
un garçon qui est capable de scorer
c'est capable de passer on lui a dit
qu'on voulait être ambitieux qu'on
voulait un mec exactement comme lui on
le regardait déjà l'anne dernière il a
vite dit oui donc ça a été assez
rapidement bien vu le Canadien se met le
public orleéanais in the pocket dès son
premier match à
commès qui s'ess c'est d
c'est face à PO Smith fait gagner son
équipe 21 points meilleur marqueur de
l'OLB
ou intégration réussie moins d'un mois
après son arrivée en
France depuis que je suis là tout le
monde est adorable les coéquipiers sont
top les coach travaillent bien il
m'aident à devenir un meilleur joueur
tout le staff est hyper accueillant je
me sens comme à la maison
ici et qu'est-ce que vous voulez
accomplir ici gagner je veux gagner je
veux qu'on monte en première division
c'est le plus gros objectif de l'équipe
et c'est ma
[Musique]
mission au commencement il y a toujours
la passion un enfant de la balle touche
à tout
il fait ses premiers dribles et marque
ses premiers paniers devant la caméra de
sa
mère il a toujours travaillé dur il nous
faisait nous lever à 6h du matin et nous
disait je dois aller
m'entraîner il faut savoir quelque chose
sur pour le basket il sera toujours à
l'heure pour le reste vous pouvez
oubl c'est vrai
il avait toujours une balle avec lui il
driblait dans la maison il
SH ouais c'est
step je pense qu'il a toujours l'espoir
de jouer en NBA mais pour l'instant il
suit son chemin étape par
étape j'ai grandi à 35 40 minutes de
Toronto dans une petite ville il y a pas
beaucoup de joueurs professionnels de
basket qui viennent de
là-bas j'ai vraiment envie de rendre à
cette communauté ce qu'elle m'a transmis
c'est pour pour ça que j'entraîne des
enfants après ma carrière j retournerai
pour construire des terrains de
basket 20 ans après les débuts de
Stéphane les VO tous les deux ici à
Orléan ça c'est la cathédrale plus grand
de
près wou c'est très beau c'est
impressionnant tu n'as pas lu son
histoire éc en
français comment on dit beautiful en
[Musique]
français